that afternoon did that gangster guy
come over and he put the gun in his my
head and he's like no you you're done
here because supposedly I was talking
bad about him and I was like what are
you talking about and he was just right
there
and somebody was you know like hey you
need to you need to don't do that you
know stuff like that they he just he
didn't have any any bullets inside oh
wow and he just shoot it and just to
teach me a lesson mhm so it was the
moment it was very and I was like man of
course GTI was there you know like
[Music]
wow hey everybody Welcome to LED live
today we're going to get into Alex
caso's story on uh you know how you came
to work with little light because today
is actually a Monumental day in Alex's
next chapter of his life what's going
going on Alex
well as the last day working for
fulltime and little life Studios but
I've been working with you guys I mean
for n years
volunteering for little in Spanish but
uh a decade this man has worked with our
ministry he's given a lot of blood sweat
tears to our work in fact uh I think out
of all the people that have worked
through Little Light Studios I it
correct me if I'm wrong but aren't you
kind of the longest standing you came on
board before Keith really yeah maybe
like 6 months or8 months or something
even though you weren't full-time keth
kind of joined up and and was full-time
before you were but um Alex has been
working with with this ministry longest
over anyone else other than myself I
guess maybe but man it's been a joy uh
serving with you and uh Alex has a
passion for people's personal
testimonies he has a channel called just
be blessed you should check it out we'll
put a link in the description below but
it's really neat he he loves personal
testimonies you've done some really
amazing ones over the years yeah uh
right now it's like
170 uh testimonies beautiful 170
testimonies that's that's that's awesome
I mean I hope that you continue to do
that because I like learning about why
people do what they do and and what
drove you to this point in your life um
to me uh you see this common thread of
how God is working with everybody and
there's these moments that that just
transform your life so we're going to
get in that today we're going to flip
the script and instead of you
interviewing uh I want to hear a little
bit of your story let's start all the
way back give us a little background
Alex of you know were you raised in
Christianity um what was your childhood
like well yes uh you know I'm from
Mexico I grew up in South South Mexico
and in a in a Christian home I mean my
parents they were Catholics they when
they you know they got married and I'm
the last of of of Three Brothers right
um the oldest right yeah I'm the
youngest oh you're the youngest I'm the
youngest you got two older ones there
two more and so I grew up you know as a
Christian home I didn't grew up
Catholics and all those you know things
that we need to do and you know as a
culture in Mexico sometimes you're
thinking like oh but that's Catholic no
but it's like a also in the culture so
it's very mix
sometimes you do things and
sometimes uh sometimes we do things as a
Mexican right and you think well that's
Catholic no it's kind of like if if you
don't do things it's like well you're
not you're not Mexican you don't
celebrate the Day of you know the day of
the death you know MOS so and and but
it's kind of mixed with you know the
faith too because you go Catholic Church
you know it's very mixing so as a
Christian person you know as a family
you know my parents that you know they T
me you know the the Bible the Bible
alone uh the faith of Jesus knowing
knowing the and the statutes you know
you don't you don't repeat uh uh prayers
uh you know the the four Commandments
you know the the seven day Sabbath you
know and the Ten Commandments we need to
we need to observe that so that's why I
grew up and of course you know so
growing up in Mexico with these kind of
influences around you that you thinking
that is you know it's
traditional and that's that's how as
people but you have your own believes
you know I grew up as a Christian so
he's said no I'm not I'm not doing that
kind of stuff so uh I went 3 years going
to a public school elementary school and
they were doing you know celebrating
some stuff that my parents Tau me you
know like we don't do that you know
that's not okay that's not okay I mean
and and it was kind of like you know the
guy in the corner you know I'm not
eating that kind of stuff because it was
offering to the idols you know I don't
dance that kind of stuff stuff you know
you know you know things like that yeah
so you had more of sort of an an more
innocent uh childhood yes yes growing up
that but later on you know you go to
some family members that they have you
remember those a hug antenna on the top
the satellites or something like that
you could watch all the latest and
greatest movies on Direct TV I don't
know if that was Direct TV but it was
well my cousins in that time you know I
was maybe uh you know I was like maybe
seven years old right I
mean uh all in the 80s uh and and the
thing is that they used to watch you
know MTV MH you know how it was MTV
before but it was just videos right and
you watch and listen and all the stuff
and and which music is so incredibly
powerful over our um character
development you know what I mean like
like there there's there's been quotes
from um bothus and and I mean people in
the 6th Century BCE uh that basically
say listen if you want to examine a a
people's character look at the music
that they listen to it can actually
shape that so if you're paying attention
to that type of worldly music ultimately
it's going to impact your decisions down
the road yeah and very interesting what
you're saying because that first you
know of course you listen you know what
your parents that listen and more like
traditional music and you know what is
but and that kind of music my cousin
they listen you know rock and roll you
know you know rock and heavy metal and
things like that so of course you know
bonji you know
Tesla uh poison you know those kind of
groups you know in the 80s you know Gans
roses and everything so you just listen
that kind of stuff you're thinking like
that's really cool right and then later
on you know uh uh somebody gave me a
tape of Guns and Roses when I was in
Middle School and that was just like
the idol I mean that was just the music
and and I used to listen some crazy
music Just to let you I mean just to
share uh uh angels of Hell or Hell
Angels is a group from South America and
just the music I mean they used to say a
lot of bad things about God I'm not
kidding you I don't want to say that but
just you know have you heard people
saying I like the music I don't care
about what they say but I like the
Rhythm yeah people don't really probably
dive too deep into their their sort of
You Know lyrics and you know why did
they say that or why did they do that I
mean there was a lot of bands like tulle
and and Rage Against the Machine and all
sorts stuff that I I was also watching
or paying attention to in the same era
and um yeah I mean I know that those
things directly influen my decisions
down the road yeah so in seventh grade
that was if you want to find out like
where was the moment you know you grew
up as a Christian you you go to church
and you know Youth and everything and
when I was like 13 13 and a half you
know like that 14 before 15 I'm sure you
know start listen to Aussie osbor I us
to put that Aussie here oh wow and my
and my yeah I used to I mean I used to
have long hair you know and I used to
let it grow and I used to dye my hair in
green red all black and and I don't know
I mean it's just that type I know that
type of music yeah it goes to the
lifestyle yeah music kind of bypasses
all of our mental thinking and logical
reasoning and everything and it cuts
straight to the heart and so I think
when you when you really bypass the
mechanisms in the brain and you're just
like planting you know words and
memories burned into your memory pool um
th those those things they you start to
see you kind of start dressing like
those artists or you start talking like
them or if you you see them I mean
that's why music videos were so powerful
you start engaging in the things that
you're watching yeah and the thing is
that I used I changed my dress mhm you
know all black and you know teachers
like you know all those black teachers
and everything and and the thing is that
maybe you're going to be asking me did
your parents see that I mean what they
were thinking yeah what did they think
well it's very sad what I'm going to say
but lying it was the king of my
life so you're like oh yeah I'm not in
anything bad yeah I'm not doing that I
mean I'm going to go to some friend's
house we're going to do just a little
birthday you know and and no I mean I
was there at the other side of the you
know I grew up in the big city you know
the capital right so I was there the
other side of where I used to live and
you know smoking drinking you know and
do all the stuff you know but the thing
is that in Mexico I mean I don't know
right now but it's very sad sometimes
you're thinking oh it's kind of cute or
funny or something but
you don't have to you need to be like
you know 21 to go to the store and and
purchase a alcohol MH you know you need
to I mean you can go in the little store
in the corner and they say hey I would
like to have you know a 40 or something
like that and they just sell it to you
and you see the little kids like maybe
like five six years old go and ask for
the 40 for the dad and the little kid is
Walking with the 40 and give it to I
mean it's very sad you know and and and
that was in the time you don't have to
have a ID to buy that kind of stuff wow
so you're like 13 14 and listen that
kind of music hang out with the wrong
crowd and and you know started doing all
this stuff really young age so you start
engaging in rebellious activities and uh
I mean at this time are you still
attending church do you kind of have one
foot in the world one foot out yes uh I
used to go to church my dad you know it
gets to that point that what are you
saying that rebellions because because
uh you know now I'm I'm a parent you
know I'm thinking like wow how how much
I I give to my parents you know like
like to to get to the point that they
they explode or or something like that
um yeah uh my I remember my dad someone
hey you know it's time to go to church
you know and I used to
dress not very like you very nice to go
to church or something like that like
t-shirts and everything like not very
nice what they saying or things like
that and I used to tell my dad if you
want me to go to church I'm gonna dress
like this and I was like
15 and I'm sure my dad was something but
he didn't he said okay that's fine but
you go to church and of course you go to
church and you're like thinking about
con I mean whatever is in your mind you
know but the thing is that they never
say but you stay home you know come over
here you know things like that you say
no you go to church but now I I I
can I mean I can think that I hurt my
parents mhm mhm very bad yeah you don't
think about that during the time that
you're going through that I had a very
similar experience as well I was you
know starting to hang out with the wrong
people starting to engage in the wrong
activities and um you know even against
the caution of my my parents I remember
having conversations with my dad and and
and him telling me you know like I don't
think you should go to Hollywood and do
that and I was like ah yeah whatever dad
I'm going to go there and do my thing
and and I look back on it now I mean I I
I probably severely uh hurt them in you
know their hopefulness that I would
engage into you know something of a of a
quality of you know life or something
and instead of just trying to chase Fame
and money um so I think when I came back
into the ministry um obviously they were
happy about that but we've had some
conversations about that too so yeah you
don't you don't think about your actions
as harming your parents but you know
many times it's like we as parents we
can see further down the line than you
can see when you're a kid and we know
this road is going in a bad Direction
exactly exactly so that was the time I'm
not kidding you the I mean the seventh
grade to senior that was crazy years I
mean we talking about like five six
years
of like nothing got a lot of selfish
living exactly MH and and uh it was it
was some moments
that that I was like what I'm doing here
you know I'm saying like like God saved
me for that situation like of course it
was God I mean for that situation that
sit and I was like the thing is that you
don't learn for the first one I don't
know why like why is not the first one
you think like oh my goodness I need to
just stop and go to God right now know
but but I didn't you know until later on
um um so what was your kind of like
transformation what really brought you
back into a space where you even wanted
a relationship with God yeah well let me
tell you my my mle brother always in the
church like seriously I Cann I even
think about like he did something really
like really bad like something what I
did you know my older brother yeah we
need to pray for him his name is O so
somebody want to pray for him please uh
but my middle brother always in the
church you know he was married I was
maybe uh I don't know maybe like 17 16
or something like that but um of course
you know dressing and listening to music
and you know things like that and and he
came to me one time and every time I see
my brother I'm not kidding it's like my
stomach he was like of course you know
Darkness and Light you canot mix that
you know so it's like every time I see
my brother's like hi how you
doing that's it I mean don't tell me
what to do or you know anything like
that but let me tell you I I I really I
believe that he pray a lot before I
going to he's going to talk to me what
he's going to say to me because he was
the Holy Spirit wow he come to me and
told me can you give me two hours of the
24 hours God gives you and I'm like man
that's very cool what you said you know
but I never heard that before you know
but it was a huge powerful thing because
that means that the time you live in
doesn't belong to you right so can you
give me 2 hours of what the 24 hours God
gives you right and I'm like w that's
really cool so okay I said two hours I'm
going to hang out with my friends hurry
up I mean I had some attitude like
mhm yeah like no patient or nothing
right so I was say okay sounds good so I
was sit down so he come to me and share
with me and the Book of Daniel The Book
of Daniel is the Judgment Day and the I
don't remember exactly but the the
Asian the older you know the you know he
sit down and the books are open mhm so
judgment so it's kind of like okay this
is the book of memory The Book of Life
the book of you know so every time you
you he was told me said this kind of
book is the all the all the things that
we done and it's written down everything
I I I remember um hearing a sermon on
this one time that really kind of stuck
in my mind because because we've we've
all grown up with this idea that God is
writing down everything you know he's up
there just waiting for us to mess up and
then he's writing it down so he could
like show you but it's really the devil
that's the accuser right that's right
what if God was writing down all of
those things to show the pattern of your
life and he's looking for that specific
moment that gives him the right to save
you and it's like like look look look
right here right here Alex thought of me
and he started like like he gave me two
hours of his time out of the day it's
like that that thought totally changed
the way that God was you know like he's
just up there trying to write stuff down
that that writing of stuff down is so
that we can see a record of what
happened down here and we will see how
many times God tried to reach somebody
how many times that they said no you
know and and and God basically gave them
what they wanted hey don't want you God
he I tried 500,000 times to reach that
person eventually I had to give them
what they wanted you know and so it just
it's an interesting way to to look at it
but I think God writes him down not
obviously for his own reasons but but
it's for us to see where God has worked
in our lives I'm sure I'm sure because
he my my brother was tell me say this is
the book you is all the stuff that we
done right and he said but let me tell
you he said this is The Book of Life The
Book of Life is whatever You' done here
before if you don't have the blood of
the
Lamb you cannot erase that you need to
have the blood of the lamb and change
your life you need to give your life to
to Jesus and that's going to erase that
you know so you can have be in the book
I mean it was I was like hm I mean you
know that that's pretty cool you know
like wow and then he went to the Book of
Revelation and he was telling me say you
know what happened you know after a
thousand years you know Jesus is going
to come and then we're going to go to
heaven for a thousand years but after a
thousand years the Bible said the
Jerusalem the New Jerusalem is going to
come down the holy city is going to come
down now with the redeemers inside right
mhm but outside the city it's going to
be the second death mhm it doesn't have
second Resurrection the second
Resurrection it doesn't have no power
mhm the the caso's family is going to be
inside I don't want to see my little
brother to be outside the
city I've actually thought of this
moment in my own family as well I that
that thought has been on my mind of just
like man you know we're all in the
valley of decision here we're all
accountable for all of us choosing God
or not and it's like what if yeah our
direct family members don't choose I
mean think of that moment exactly that
there will be a group inside and there
will be a group outside there's no
middle ground you're either on Satan's
side or you're on God's side just only
two sides that's said wow so he just
told me about that and I'm just like why
like I never thought of that that appro
right and I was like okay two hours I'm
out of here right did you go party that
night yeah oh man so I didn't know if
I'm just just to be honest to you I I
you know I went and I walk and hang out
with my friends stuff like that but I
don't remember exactly just to be honest
to you it was like next week or that
weekend was planted exactly and that's
what I I totally believe that when we
whatever we meet people or you see
somebody over there and you had
something like you know what I'm going
to share this track you know I'm going
to be sharing it's just a SE
the holy spirit is the one that's going
to be helping you to see the fruit we
are the seed casters we're not the
convictor that's the job of the Holy
Spirit our job is to share the
information and respond when the Holy
Spirit tells us to open our mouth
exactly yeah so like I said it was I
don't know if it was three months three
weeks I mean I don't know but God
started working on your heart yes and
and let me tell you I went I was in a
party with some friends stuff like that
outside in some house and we were maybe
like 15 people you know like you know
boys and girls you know stuff like that
and I don't know I mean I always since
young young age I mean I don't know I
mean I have this you know I'm kind of
like visual guy you know I that's why
we're in media I like that kind of stuff
I always have like if I see you here I
don't know why but I'm thinking like
different
angles maybe you see I mean you always
camer a true filmmaker at heart I see
things in scenes as well when I hear
music I actually pictures come into my
mind MH so it's it's just a so I was
sitting down you know and it was sat I
remember it was Saturday night because
on Friday evening I mean it was not too
much party so I I was coming home like
around 10: or something like that but on
Saturday I say longer but I was sitting
down with my other friends right and you
and I had this you know everybody you
know a group over here they were talking
about like what they're going to do with
this girl uh this group over here
They're laughing they're doing nty
things and over here they're just making
drinks and I mean you know things like
that you know crazy stuff so I was just
sitting down and just kind of
contemplating what's going onh you know
kind of like sit down and just look like
you know things like that
right it was a 15 seconds that's what I
believe it was like a 10 seconds 15
seconds that the Holy Spirit just had
this opportunity MH and I believe you
know that prayers are for many people
parents Grandma things like that so I
had this thought it was not my thought
let me tell you because in those the
kind of time you know thinking
MH what are you doing here this is not
your world H and I'm thinking like whoa
whoa whoa where does this thought come
from I mean that's not M mhm and I'm
like what and I just kind of like Get it
like this is God this is not me MH and I
just like what are you doing here that's
not your world and I'm
like I put my drink in the S and I stand
up and I told my
buddy I'm out and you know when I'm you
said you're out like not turning back
when you say hey I see you later yeah
I'm going to come back later but I tell
like you know what I'm out and my butt
is like what are you doing it's 11:30
Saturday night man this is just starting
right now mhm and he's like no I'm out I
don't need to be here so I went home
early for Saturday and the next and
Monday or something I wanted to read my
Bible wow and I start nobody give me
Bible study M my parents didn't say hey
you need to see down we're going to I'm
going to tell I'm going to tell you what
do you believe you know all the stuff
not I knew that my parents they had you
know my dad you know lots of you know
different you know Christian books and
stuff like that but it had this you know
like a Bible study thing you know and I
grabb um it's kind of interesting my dad
um had a Catholic Bible there big ones
big letters I don't know why I always
like the Catholic Bible because I don't
know it's heavy maybe it's kind of
intimidated I don't know I really like
it so I gra the Catholic Bible and I got
this Bible study and I started with the
Bible but it's kind of heavy you know
but I open the Bible and had some
questions and answer but the answer was
in the Bible and I was the question and
I'm like
is in the bible say that the answer I
mean no way so I go
Matthew what and I go over here is like
annoy question and whatever whatever
book in the Bible was the answer I'm
like I couldn't believe it that was my
first experience having a Bible study
and I did it myself w wow you know you
think of just because you grew up in a
Christian family and you just went to
church on the weekends and things you
you you you would naturally assume that
you know people are familiar with the
concepts of the Bible but that's not
always the case you know it takes your
own individual investigation and that's
hopefully where we're leading all the
young children and stuff is to to build
that foundation with their own
interactions with God and I think that's
what makes it powerful is when your eyes
actually see it and you're the one that
that that sees those two things together
yeah yeah so when I saw that I was like
wow I mean this is this is this is great
so that was saying my senior
year when I had my study my you know and
I was going to high school you know and
maybe sometime late because I used to
get up at 5 in the morning to do my
Bible study to go there and let me tell
you the principle
before after reading my Bible you know I
cut my hair fix it up very nice if you
told me you need to put your your shirt
under tuck your shirt in tuck your shirt
in I mean that's ridiculous man I mean
like I don't dress like that you know
and after reading the Bible I mean
seriously like God you know the power
the the gospel you know changed us right
you don't going to be dressing like that
you're going to listen to that kind of
music because no I mean now Jesus saying
you're asking the Holy Spirit to be with
you you right he's GNA guide you like
okay don't do this don't eat this you
know transform your life so all those
black and dress and you know all the
stuff you used to you know used to have
and and I remember the principal of the
middle the high school come to me and it
say casos I mean they don't tell you
about your name always with the last
name down there and he said ctios I
don't know what you're doing but I've
been seeing you for all these three
years High School down there is three
years and he said but you're doing
something different I don't want to know
what you're doing but I just want to let
you know keep doing what you're doing
because it's working that's what he told
me I was like wow you know thank you you
know and I was going to church and
everything and I was baptized and uh
December 28th
1996 wow that was when I graduated high
school
okay in in 1996 96 so uh I graduated in
1997 but so that was my that was my only
first time to be baptized because my
daddy was this kindy mentality you know
of course you know I don't want my kids
to they need to know this is serious
stuff you know uh they you know they're
going to be knowing what they doing you
know so I started that but the important
thing is the reading the Bible I found
those amazing Bible verses yeah that in
in
Psalms in Psalms chapter
25 um versus I don't remember the other
verses but um it says that forget the
sense of your
youth and to me Scotty I mean that was
like a cold water in my soul mhm like
he's going to forget all the things that
I done I mean that was like a taste of
Mercy MH I was so I I just grabb it I
was like it's a very interesting thought
to think of God forgetting something
like like we're talking about the one
that created everything always has lived
he's never been you know not living and
it's like his mind is superior to every
every other mind that could possibly
ever be created and probably
collectively together yeah but he
chooses to say no no that part I'm GNA
I'm GNA not even think about it yeah
that's right so I'm G to I'm going to
read it because it's very powerful
powerful verse beautiful in Psalms 25
verse starting verse four says show me
your ways oh Lord teach me your paths
Lead Me In Your Truth and teach me for
you are the god of my salvation all you
I wait all day remember oh Lord you
Tender Mercies and your loving
kindness that they are from the all
verse 7 he said do not remember the sins
of my youth nor my transgression
according to your mercy remembers me for
your goodness sake oh Lord and verse
eight good and upright is the Lord
therefore he teach sinners in the way M
it's beautiful so it's it's it's to me
it's like wow I mean he's the one he's
going to teach the Sinners the way how
did it go like I don't I forgive all the
sense of my youth but it's right there
of your Youth and let me tell you it's
like wow and that and that moment I I
was really thinking like
wow that that that afternoon did that
gangster guy come over and he put the
gun in his my head and he's like no you
you're done here because supposedly I
was talking bad about him and I was like
what are you talking about and he was
just right there and
somebody was you know like hey you need
to you need to don't do that you know
stuff like that but he just he didn't
have any any bullettin say oh wow and he
just shoot it and just to teach me a
lesson mhm so it was the moment it was
very and I was like man of course Gotti
was there you know like wow and know
another moment they I was just thinking
you know after you you find in the Bible
that God it was
there what I was doing that Saturday
night we hang hang out with some friends
MH and shooting some cars MH and one of
the cars he was from federales Mexico
and they were following
us and inside of me is like I need to
get out of this truck because if they
get me they got me I mean I'm going to
go to a favorite prison just to go
shooting people's car you're not
supposed to do that MH mhm so you know
what I did is in one of the corners and
and the cars that were following us in
one of the corners I say I need to jump
and I did in one of the jumps and I just
jump and I went under a car just to hit
it myself wow and uh it's just and my
and my friends they went to they went to
jail for a few months wow and I was it
was not me you know and many things you
know but and to me it's like God was
there you know it's still still there
you know and every day you know but uh I
just thank that God that and and in the
word of God you find truth you find
Salvation and always he's knocking the
door you know like come daughter come
son you know I have a plans for you and
it's better than what you have right
right is that fun running around in a
car shooting at people and then
fearfully you know trying to like I'm
going to get caught like like is that
fun basically I think if you really sat
down and were honest with it you would
say God's ways are always better they're
always full of peace and happiness and
joy I mean the joy aspect when you're
living in a life like that there's no
joy in that yeah things are funny or sin
can be fun for a season but it's not
joyous you know like like the Bible
describes that that a relationship will
give you yeah so you're starting to feel
the pull to come back to God at what
point did you kind of even stumble
across uh our work and and what was that
that like yeah well let me tell you uh
that was in 2011 mhm and uh you know I
was just here in United States you know
married you know with two beautiful
daughters stuff like that but in 2011 uh
I used to go to this site it's called
Audi verse H you know back then it was
MP3 those things and and I used to go
there and download you know I mean it's
free sites that you say they can you can
download for free you know
sermons and I used to listen sermons and
go to bed with listen my sermons I mean
that was you know that's what I want
that's what I was doing and and I listen
a lot of sermons but it was one sermon
it's called American Idols by Scott
Meyer and I was like hm I don't know
who's that guy but the title maybe
they're gonna be talking about music
right I mean American Idols you know so
I downloaded and that evening you know
by 11:00 or something like that my
wife's sleeping and I'm like like my
grand listen to my sermon
right you were talking there and you
were talking about how the
superheroes come from and the all
directors and writers said that the
superheroes there you know from
different gods and civilization and
Greeks Egyptians and all stuff and and
I'm like what he's talking about H right
like what this guy the more powerful
thing it was is that you were playing
those clips of those movies and let me
tell you when I was in young age you
know like when I was a kid you know I
mean 1989 Batman was in the movie
theater I mean I was there MH and that
was Chang my world you know Batman it
was for me is it was part of me why
because it's not a person that has like
powers on it's human but during the day
is or you know bruise way you know the
night is the dark night you know it's
bad man so to me it's like wow I mean
I'm a nice Christian guy right MH but
the night time time I mean I just put my
different t-shirt and I'm become a
different person so that's why it was
like you know Batman me is like wow
that's my guy right so when you were
talking about Batman and all those clips
and I'm was like what you talking about
me I watched that movie for 20 times I
know the whole thing and that but you
were saying you know um you know
exposing that they were attacking God
the Ten Commandments that the true about
this centu message and and and God you
know Ten Commandment you know stuff like
I was like whoa I never heard I never
see that in in that angle MH and it was
and I was listening to it I was not
watching you your presentation you know
how it is right I mean the power to mind
is more powerful imaginating thing so
the next day I went to my computer you
know big Monitor and I went to check it
out I was like who are little lios and I
watched a few clips and I mean it was
only a few clips and and on a YouTube
channel and and it was like wow and and
it was you know I told my girl we're not
watching that kind of stuff in Disney
we're not doing any kind of stuff you
know and we get clean the house wow and
I need to share that with my girls you
know teach them but the thing is that I
call you guys because I was like this
message is in English you guys have this
in
Spanish and and and I remember you know
somebody answer the pH I don't know you
or or Brandon or something because
sometimes to me it was kind of like the
same voice
Brandon and I did have similar voices
yeah seriously talking the phone so I
was like that was that was because we
hung out so much you know you kind of
mold together when you when you do that
yeah so I told him like Hey you know I
just want to help you know you guys do
have in Sp no we don't have anybody
maybe somebody sometimes they help us
but so I was like semi I mean I would
have to translate I mean my uh my mother
tongue you know Spanish right so I was
like I can help you know because I saw
the need of my
my community right the Hispanic
Community the Latino Community I was
like these message need to know in
Spanish and I I want to help right I you
know so you guys sent me a file I mean I
still have those those files and the
emails you know back then
2011 and and it's I send you the first
email uh uh Magic Kingdom and I'm like
okay let's do the Magic Kingdom you know
um uh yeah and the tools back then were
very very like rough so when you would
do a translation I mean it was
painstakingly slow you had to type out
not only just what's being said but I
mean the little time code that was on
there yeah and it just took months to
even do one video now it's like AI one
click of a button [__] change language
exactly and and and you got to be uh
very uh you know sometimes you not think
about it like 45 minutes 1 hour sermon I
mean we're talking about months of work
yeah we talk about like maybe like 38 to
42 Pages mhm mhm of translat people
talking you know and sharing and stuff
like that so it was a lot of work you
know and I'm also I mean I'm working 40
hours maybe plus 60 hours because I you
know over time stuff like that but I
used to get up at 4 in the morning to
translate you know and and uh Thea
system of worship you know and all the
stuff and I remember you know you know
these artists you know sell the Sal of
the to the devil you know Translating
that thing and I mean it's just those
moments so I started just to be a
translator you know person and then in
2012 um I remember we're talking back
and forth and and you guys is like what
about we because I was like okay it's
nice to put as subtitles so make it work
fast but I told them I told you guys you
know my people need to hear the voice
yeah you know and so I went um U
Paradise back 10 Paradise uh to do the
voice over for uh controller One MH and
it was hard to do the voice over because
I didn't know you know the voice over so
that's what we started so the whole
point is that you know I helped uh uh
four or five documentaries you know to
bring it into Spanish you know
replacement God you know in Spanish you
know sudy in Spanish so in 2012 later on
I mean I remember that day the uh you
guys invite me and say we want somebody
to go to the to do this Battlefield
Hollywood in Spanish the seminars and
I'm like I'm just the translator guy you
know what I'm saying I'm just the behind
the scene I was not thinking you know
like oh someday I'm going to be in the
front you know I just want to help and
and I said well let me pray for that and
I accept it later on and and going to
different places you know Guatemala
Canada Mexico many times Puerto Rico for
I mean many times around you know the
United States and to go you know
bilingual sharing Engish English and
Spanish but uh it's so it's so neat you
know yeah we went to Florida together
the remember that yeah M Florida uh we
went to um another events events and uh
big
events and different places you know
Houston and Orlando and things like that
so I was there you know volunteering for
n years MH yeah still I mean keep in
mind he was literally spending 40 hours
at work and then waking up in the we
hours of the morning and and working on
it just little bits at a time and so you
know it it was really neat when it came
around to I think
200 16 17 18 when did we when did we
officially on 2020 2020 okay so it took
us even from that point of you
Moonlighting for seven years yeah about
oh uh uh like how long did you work
before you came on full board full
fulltime nine years nine years yeah 2011
to I mean that's a that's an investment
of time and you know we just never
really were stable enough to to have a
full just dedicated person to the
Spanish um side of things so 2020 you
got the invitation to come out and and
do this full-time and that was a big
move for your whole family to move from
Oregon we moved from California now we
live in Tennessee and so moving you from
Oregon to Tennessee that's that's a big
big change yes big change and how'd that
go well the Lords Works in different
ways I mean let me tell you because uh
that was in April when it was in the
invitation and I was like wow that's my
dream job you know finally you know
full-time you know things like that and
of course you know fixing the house you
know trying to sell it you know and you
know you know things like that but um
trying to sell the house and let me tell
you uh that the person was trying to
sell the house is like you know this you
know right now the market is so good and
the house going to be like less than a
month it's going to be sell in the house
I was like okay right on 3
months nothing and it was very very hard
because it's like you know like you know
where we going to put our stuff you know
things like that you know a lot of
stress you
know and and September 8th September 8th
uh he was uh the fires in Sal Oregon the
aletas fires wild fires and
2,500 residents burned down to the
ground and one of them it was my home
yes I remember this this now this is
very close proximity to to um you moving
out here yeah yeah I mean was it weeks I
don't remember it was days yeah days
yeah because we were like I remember I I
Shar with you guys like hey I think
somebody's you know going to buy the you
know the house and I'm out like in two
weeks I can just move right and the the
fire just show up like and and um
reminds me the story of right before the
fires actually happened I think it was
your daughter had a dream that the house
was burning down to the ground and she
told your wife and tell us about that we
had home insurance but it was not in our
name we were living in my my in-law's
house and uh because we were helping him
and stuff like that and uh he had
insurance but you know he's older stuff
like that so it was not in our name
right so the thing is that um my
daughter had a dream and share with my
other daughter and and Sh you know
sometimes young kids like he don't share
you know I don't know what's going but
it was very tragedy just to share that
with you it was not just like oh I had
that dream you know it was like she was
kind of leaving in that you know like
she get up and and she was thinking like
the whole exactly so everything was on
fire and she couldn't open a window and
Fire there open the windows of fire
there she couldn't leave the house
because it was fire all over the place
and it was very bad and so uh she shared
that with my with my daughter uh oldest
daughter and my oldest daughter's like I
need to share that with my with Mom and
uh my wife and and my old daughter went
out one afternoon and she's like Mom I
need to share that something with you
and this has happened and my my wife is
like wow I mean it's it's very
interesting that you know sometimes some
of the kids you know they share
something you're like oh you ate too
much pizza you know last night or
something like that but thank God you
know the holy spirit is like no this is
this is true something's coming or
something like that so my wife is like
no we need to we need to have our own
insurance you know my you know my my dad
is older and stuff like that so we got
we call we we switch and like in that in
that parking lot my wife you just call
and the pap and you know 10 minutes you
have and your name you have home
insurance and like a week later I'm not
kidding you the house burned yeah I
think it was like 5 days I think is what
you said so from the time that his wife
made the switch um of the insurance
company yeah 5 days later burnt down to
the ground lost everything and you moved
out here with literally the shirt on
your back I'm not kidding you I mean
seriously I I I I think I came when I
came from Mexico came to United States
in 1999 with more clothes yeah seriously
with more clothes you know because let
me tell you it was a Hu huge shock I
mean it's not like when you go to the
mall or go places to buy clothes you're
thinking oh look at that red one do you
think I like you know the red one or the
blue one you know yeah I was like no I
don't have I don't want to feel like you
know like buying a clothes like leave me
alone you know like I lost everything
yeah you know memories and stuff and I
know there's stuff M but it's yours I
mean I I mean I want that that that
jeans that I bought it and you know 2005
you know like I like that old jeans
never going to have you know never going
to have it you know again so that was
quite an adjustment on you coming out
here that's how you began work with us I
remember we would slowly see you come in
with new
outfits like Alex has been shopping yeah
like it's new you know like but it's
been an absolute Joy um when you joined
up with us our team was just starting to
really expand grow you you
saw us uh go from a borrowed space to we
actually um paid rent when we before we
bought this building that we we in right
now we had rent and that was the only
time that in the history of the ministry
in 15 years that we' never even paid for
anywhere to to be God had provided a
space constantly for us to work out of
and then he was just uh you know opening
doors left and right and then we got a
chance to to get this building and
everybody kind of got their own little
office space we were quite crammed in
that in that one space that we were
using um when you first showed up I
think there was like six of us in a one
single room in one single room we used
to do that stuff like that and we were
making videos for you guys yeah so it's
been it's been a beautiful journey to to
see you coming along board and um you
know really helping us out the Spanish
stuff has has gone out into the world
and we've given lots of them away um we
we we we wish we had a whole team to
dedicate to that CU I know the Spanish
world there's so many more Believers
than even in the English world it's like
the majority of the world speak Spanish
yes yes 680 million something yeah so
it's like uh you know I think it's a
it's a very awesome thing that you've
added to our ministry and it's been a
it's been a blessing having you aboard
you're now you've accepted a job and a
calling to go and work in a university
yes um so tell us a little bit about
that well um you know the first year is
going to be you know like you know
managing the office stuff like that but
they have a mission to build a studio
there and I mean just to and you know
they asked me say you had some you know
some tools to you can bring and we we
you know we've been watching you you
know what you do and and uh we would
love to you come to help us you know in
that in that matter so I was like wow
that's a that's a you know opportunity
let's put it that way you know and I was
like wow
listen you know I pray a lot and and I
accept it and it's kind of weird to say
you know um this is my dream job you
know like to be here finally you know
but uh uh God is good I mean go God put
us different places for a reason you
know exactly and and to be honest the
way I've began to view Ministry work is
we're all on the same team man so we
have you know the same common goal let's
try to take as many many people to
Heaven as possible let's Inspire as many
people as we possibly can to make that
decision for Jesus and you know
sometimes that work takes its form in
many different ways but together we're
still uh lock step and we're you know
headed in the same direction so you know
you're always welcome to come back and
do some work with us and I think you
know you're still planning on doing some
Moonlighting with the with the
translation oh yeah but um I you know we
want to inspire you guys um to get
involved in Ministry work really
honestly I think we're at the day and
age that every single person needs to
have some active involvement in the
ministry if you're not working for your
local church or you're not helping
support some kind of ministry work or
translating or or just lending your
expertise I mean people don't people
don't even really think about but if you
don't have any direct access to either
work in a Ministry capacity you can
always send money to help Ministries
grow and help them push the workout and
so I believe that everybody should be
involved in this work and I want to
inspire you guys you know get involved
if it's not financially supporting and
we're not just saying hey look you
should just donate to us you should do
pick a Ministry that you really believe
is doing something that you're
passionate about and put some energy
behind them we only have existed at
little light because of the generosity
of people and this work unfortunately as
much as we'd like to think it's free
it's not it takes time and money and
resources and all these things to put
messages out there and we do our best to
share these messages for free yeah and
you know even selling DVDs that just
that money just went right back into the
pool so that we could hire other people
and do that so I just wanted to let you
guys know um you know get in the habit
of supporting God's work and and we want
to thank you first and foremost all of
you that do support this work because we
got a chance to work together because of
your generosities thank you guys yeah
yeah and I'm going to add to it because
uh you know sometimes you know we
support different things you know you
know maybe you buy coffee or a monthly
thing of days you listen to you know uh
membership for $70
$30 15 bucks net yeah stuff like that
you know constantly if it's not you know
um mediable you buying something you
know uh can you imagine if you say you
know what I'm not going to be drinking
my Starbucks for a month you know one
time even on one I those $7 or or
something like that you know $20 send it
to a Ministry you know and and I just
want to be saying you know support the
Spanish Department you know write down
in Spanish or little Studios or
something like that uh uh we do things a
lot for free I mean just to be honest
with you you know and and just support
this man if that this little life
Studios really change your life if you
know that this is a huge blessing and
and go talk to God I'm not kidding you
go talk to God and say you know what I'm
going to put this a little percentage
this is for little life Studios for this
ministry because they're really each
week bringing something new is going to
change my life so I just want to
encourage you he didn't tell me anything
so I just want to tell you support
little life Studios we do a lot of
things a lot of different Ministries and
uh and and and the reason why because we
want to share with other people the love
of God Amen that's the whole thing you
know and it cost money like you were
saying you know it cost money it cost
money you know we need to pay amen but
overall even if you don't do that you
can simply pray for usen and that we
covet more than anything else keep us in
your prayers keep Alex and and his
family yes in your prayers as he's
opening up a new chapter of life here
and you're you're heading out a whole
another venture that could potentially
win a lot of college students to the
gospel you know so um I want to really
thank you for your time that you have
spent with our ministry and wish you the
best but this is not a goodbye that's
right this is just a uh you know I'm
going to be rooting you on and uh thank
you so much for the work that you have
given to us thus far yeah yeah also keep
in mind and keep in prayer Alex's
Ministry just be blessed if you guys
really are inspired by people's stories
people's testimonies you know you want
some encouragement you've got a lot of
different testimonies on there of people
that you would not have expected ever to
give their heart to God and it's like
when you hear their stories and God won
their heart all of us have friends
family members people we know of that
are not walking with with with the
Christ right now and and you know pray
for those people and then you know get
inspired by listening to some of the
stories about the ways God reached those
people so just be blessed check them out
YouTube page like them subscribe and uh
definitely keep Alex in your prayer in
that Venture yes yes and maybe somebody
said why testimonies right why why why
testimonies and the thing is that to me
it's like so powerful I mean I'm not
kiding you I mean your story my story is
uh to bring there a lot of people out
there that have the stories like us you
know but to me is like how how this
person was from point A to point B how
was the middle thing when when Gotti was
inter intervened I said you know what
this is my son this is my daughter and
I'm going to work on that you know they
make that decision you know and we're
still working right I mean until Jesus
come right but the thing is that those
kind of stories like I want to share
with it with people and that's my
driving you know like you know when do
you have time for that I don't know uh
everybody has a hobby right my hobby is
like translate people ask me like what
do you do for hobby you go golfing I was
like no I
translate oh I oh I do on you know my
Thursday nights it's my you know couple
hours I take you know this is what I do
this is my hobby that's what I like to
do so you know keep some hobby that is
going to be sharing the gospel that's
right seriously we home it's what you'll
be doing throughout eternity I imagine
that when uh this whole mess is all said
and done and we are are living in a
sinless environment in a blissful
environment people are still going to
come to you and be curious about how God
God won your heart and so throughout
eternity I imagine we'll be sharing
stories about those moments that God got
to me and uh there I have no no nothing
to offer and God still bestowed a lot of
love upon me that I did not deserve and
I know he can do that for you so yeah
awesome thank you for listening and uh
don't forget to like And subscribe to
this and if you want to get involved um
definitely uh check us out on little
light stud studios. TV we've got a lot
of different ways you can you can
support this ministry through patreon
you can um go to lightwear dotshop buy
our cool t-shirts that support the
gospel and hey you're promoting
something that uh hopefully will have a
lasting influence upon people and uh but
uh overall thank you for watching and
we'll see you next time let me tell
[Music]
you
oh
[Music]
if you're looking for good wholesome
educational content for your children
subscribe to our new channel little like
kids there has been very few movies in
the history of the world that have
completely changed our world and in 1999
a movie titled The Matrix hit the world
stage these stories are often told and
seen over and over again is it simply
just to make money or is there something
more nefarious behind
it
[Music]
[Applause]